young people who had just graduated from
college or parents of college or
university applicants were telling me
how shocked they were by some of the
anecdotes and some of the research and
datanomics showing how
prevailing sex ratios on a college
campus can have a huge impact on on the
way
kids on campus view dating how so
so in datonomics i did a an analysis of
about 40 major
public and private universities and i
ranked them by their their sex ratios
and i paired that ranking with
students own descriptions of what dating
life is like on these college campuses
and the descriptions came courtesy of
the college prowler um
uh
you know college review book it's
basically a book written for applicants
you know so if you want to know what the
um
you know what the
engineering program is like at
university of georgia or what the
cafeteria food is like or in this case
what what the dating life is like there
you can read you can read and it's all
written by current or recent students so
you can get a sense of what what life is
like you know on these college campuses
and it was really it was
it was really striking how differently
kids talked about dating at various
schools depending upon the the
prevailing sex ratios and i'll give you
some examples here
so rensselaer polytechnic institute
which is kind of a science and
engineering school in upstate new york
rpi
um
rpi is
about 70 men 30 women two you know more
than two men for every one woman
and
here's what students said about dating
at rpi
more people are involved in
relationships girls seem to become stuck
up because they're in such a minority
that they can afford to be choosy
caltech which is you know california
institute of technology in california
and if you remind me i have an i have a
funny story about caltech which i can
add at the end um
caltech is 60 40. 60 men 40 women three
women for every two three men for every
two women
uh here's what students said there about
dating
students here tend not to date that have
relationships breakups are rare and many
couples get married after caltech
um even the schools that were 50 50 it
was kind of a more it was more familiar
to me as a 50 year old guy when it came
to like what i remember about college so
tufts university which is in suburban
boston
tufts is 50 50. halfway through
sophomore year people begin to pair off
and generally stayed paired off through
junior and senior year
that's that was that's familiar to me
that's what i remember
university of miami which has a rep a
reputation as a big party school but it
also happens to be 50 50. and here's
what
what students say about dating there
random hookups are common in the
beginning but after a few months or a
year relationships take over
so compare that the schools are either
more men than women or 50 50 to some of
the schools that are disproportionately
female
i'll start with new york new york
university in new york city
and nyu is 61
female 39 percent male again three
is that
that's about representative typically
i think on average for most colleges now
it wasn't when i wrote them it was more
like
75 35 i must say not 75 it was more like
um
i'm sorry it was it was closer to 58
30
uh 42 yeah i wrote
i think this year's graduating class i
think you're right i think at least in
the us it's 60 40. it's going to be bang
on so so
yeah so nyu new york university here's
what what kids say about dating at nyu
guys take advantage of the male to
female ratio and most have no plans of
settling into a long-term relationship
boston university where actually my son
is a senior um bu is 62 percent
uh
female 38 male
here's the comment
freshman year is a sexual explosion
there are girls to go around and around
again
and lastly sarah lawrence college which
used to be an all-girls school in in
suburban new york it's now co-ed but
it's 75 percent female
25 percent male three women for every
one man
you could probably guess what i'm about
to read to you but i'll
let me share
quote the girls complain about
loneliness the guys get more than they
can handle and mindless one-night stands
are rampant
so so for me like doing the doing the
college research really kind of showed
how these prevailing sex ratios don't
just affect the statistical odds of
getting into a relationship but they
change culture they change behavior as
well yeah and rolling the clock forward
the people that graduate from those
colleges presuming that men and women
drop out at similar rates i think men
might drop out a little bit more than
women literally but probably not enough
to rebalance this uh sex ratio that
we've got and i think that
yeah you'd be about right it's saying 60
40 women to men but by 2030 the
projection is two-thirds women to
one-third men at a four-year us college
so this trend is going to continue to
get more and more pronounced
yep yeah no i mean i
i i
as i said with my first book i i you
know part of my
purpose in writing it was was reversing
that trend and trying to figure out how
we get more
more men to attend university or college
um
but that's kind of a that's a long-term
thing it's not going to solve the dating
problem in the short term well the other
thing is that dating is inherently an
individual
act right dating your dating strategy
what sort of partner you're looking for
how you're going about looking for a
partner that's something that you can
impact individually what you're trying
to do or what you would be trying to do
there by continuing to improve men's
desire to go to college that's systemic
right that's completely
that's a big broad social change that
you're trying to get to do yes it
happens individually one by one by one
but i feel like trying to impact
individuals dating
strategies
is a simpler problem than trying to
improve an entire sexes view of how to
go to college no no you're right but i
guess from my point of view the boy
problem in education isn't just a dating
problem oh yeah men don't just go to
college to get laid yeah
although your son your son did choose
one of the uh colleges that's got a
female ratio so so my son is actually
gay so he gets oh god he's ruined it
i i know i know why didn't he go to the
one with the technology college you're
75 men because because i
um
believe it or not prevailing sex ratios
have no impact on same sex data because
you can always divide by two the rules
are just thrown out of the window
but but i will say my my son
my gay my son alex says he has lots of
wonderful female friends um
um but yeah he gets no benefit from the
the oversupply of fabulous women at bu
bloody hell what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace